who doesn't love saving money stay tuned
to learn the secrets of
cost optimization with anthos
[Music]
i'm priyanka and welcome to anthos101
in the next five minutes we are going to
cover five ways to reduce your costs
using antos
so let's jump into the five and five
number one improving visibility
imagine you have an application that was
built on premises
years ago but has highly variable usage
how awesome it would be to move it to
the cloud to take advantage of auto
scaling
so you can pay for resources when you
need them and not all the time
on the other hand imagine you have an
app that is running in the cloud and
that has pretty consistent traffic
patterns
and you happen to have capacity on
premises why not move it there and
leverage your existing investments
now we know that and those provides
consistency and portability across
hybrid and multi-cloud environments
which allows you to see all the
resources you're consuming
and easily balance and rebalance them
across those environments
which means
number two reducing operational overhead
now imagine your platform operations
team which is responsible for
configuring patching and releasing
not to mention sometimes migration from
one environment to another
it is a huge overhead to do all that
across clouds and on-premises
with anthos you get a single pane of
glass for management
and configuration of resources which
improves productivity
similarly your security team that
creates deploys and enforces security
policies
across your application development life
cycles
with anthos you get to consistently
apply security policies across
all your applications spanning cloud and
on-prem
which means with the efficiencies gained
your teams can focus their energy
on building great applications number
three
modernizing monolithic apps
every organization has at least a few
monolithic applications that are costly
to scale and manage
while google cloud supports common
management of virtual machines and
containers
i'm sure you're already looking to the
future of breaking down your monolithic
applications into container based micro
services
to scale and manage your resources
efficiently
using migrate for addos you can turn
your vms into container-based apps
without having to re-architect or
re-platform manually
this helps you simplify operations such
as dynamic scaling
and integrate with other antho services
like service mesh for better resource
monitoring
and by containerizing your app you're
able to pack
more resources on less infrastructure
leading to
number four removing the need for
hypervisor
if you are running kubernetes
applications on-prem you may begin to
assess the need for third-party
hypervisors
so we have announced that later in 2020
you will be able to run and those with
no third-party hypervisors
further eliminating the management
overhead of yet another vendor
relationship
and reducing
number five optimization tools available
in google cloud marketplace if you're
already running kubernetes and looking
to optimize costs check out google cloud
marketplace which offers solutions from
commercial partners
and open source projects that take
innovative approaches to monitor
and report on resources running within
your clusters
these kubernetes applications are
pre-integrated with anthos
and deploy quickly saving you
well saving you time which saves often
circumstances beyond our control force
changes in budgets
and send us into cost saving mode as you
assess the benefits of adopting anthos
consider the cost optimizations you can
realize with improved operations
consistent monitoring modernization bare
metal
and partner technologies ready to get
started
connect with a partner or your sales
team to do an assessment of your current
hybrid and multi-cloud strategy
and read the total economic impact study
at cloud.google.com anthos
for more and those content don't forget
to subscribe and follow the anthos 101
playlist
you